[Musique]
vous voyez un mot clic qui devient
virale du jour au lendemain ou encore
des dizaines de gens qui semblent tous
militer sur les réseaux sociaux pour la
même cause
c'est peut-être vrai mais c'est
peut-être aussi de l'art trotter fing
qu'on pourrait traduire en français par
du simili tourisme le terme à ce
trotteur fing ça vient d'eux astroturf
qui est une marque de pelouse
artificielle qui imite la vraie pelouse
ou en français quand on dit si
militantisme c'est pour simili
militantisme
alors qu'est ce que la structure fing
c'est quand un groupe créé une campagne
à des fins publicitaires ou politiques
mais pour donner l'impression que c'est
un vrai mouvement social spontané on l'a
vu par exemple durant les dernières
élections américaines
une organisation russe avait créé à la
fois une campagne pro donald trump et
une campagne propre nice 1-2 quand on
voit de la structure fing on a
l'impression que plein de gens se sont
mobilisés pour la cause
alors qu'en réalité ce sont soit des
gens payés par le groupe ou encore des
bottes donc des faucons ça peut être par
exemple une compagnie qui créé des faux
comptes de clients pour faire la
promotion de son produit ou encore un
parti politique qui demande à ses
partisans de tous partagé en même temps
le même message
ça peut aussi être des faux comptes on
l'a vu par exemple durant la dernière
course au leadership du parti
progressiste conservateur de l'ontario
de nombreux faux comptes avaient tous
partagé le même mot clic pour
discréditer une des candidates
christine elliott comment reconnaître la
structure fing c'est pas toujours
évident mais il ya des indices
par exemple si on voit beaucoup de gens
partager exactement le même message en
même temps ou encore si ce sont des
comptes qui viennent d'être créées qui
n'ont presque rien partager d'autres la
structure fine contribuer à la
désinformation parce qu'on pense avoir
affaire à un vrai mouvement social alors
qu'en réalité tout a été orchestré à
l'avance et quand on voit une vraie
campagne sur les réseaux sociaux on
finit par ne plus savoir si c'est
vraiment